so my thesis is on civic production in
live streaming mobile video that is
video streamed live to the internet from
a mobile phone
um and just to get to jump right in to
give you a sense of what i'm talking
about i just want to show you a really
quick example
from two different videos the first uh
was posted
quite a while ago
not long after the
the site launched this is i did a case
study on videos on this site quick.com
hi this is paul murphy peddling words
and this is a poem another poem by
william butler yitz
it's called the ballad of wandering
angus
i went out to the hazel wood
because a fire was in my head
i cut and peeled a hazel wand and hooked
the berry to a thread
and then white moths were on the wing
and mops like stars were flickering out
i cast my berries in a stream
and caught
a little silver part
okay you get the idea
um then for a completely different
example this is a from brazil from a
producer who is i think part of the
brazilian police force
um the translation of the title is
outlaws exchange shots with the police
and die it's a little
okay so
another completely
different use of live streaming mobile
video
so
let me get my mouse back
um so really my goal for this thesis
is
explore how live streaming mobile video
is developing as a practice in general
um and then more specifically looking at
what i'm calling civic producers and how
and why they adopt use and understand
this particular technology which i'm
calling a new medium
and as i mentioned the case study of
quick.com um it's a it's a one of the
oldest sites oldest a few two and a half
years old
for live streaming mobile video it's a
mobile application at a website um so
you can stream content from your phone
as i was doing during sheila's
presentation and you can watch it live
online the site gets around a thousand
um broadcasts a day which are then
archival on the site for later
use um and in my study i found 80
countries the the site supports over 20
languages and just tons of phones um so
that's just a brief profile i'll get
more into that later
just to sort of define the terms that
i'm talking about here i kind of morphed
a few
different definitions from different
terms to to characterize what i'm
calling civic content
and so this is sort of
a match up of a bunch of those
definitions as they relate to my
subject
so
civic is being public spirited an
activity or an event that relates to
community or public affairs
and
public is you know people producing
content are authorized by serving or
representing the community and that all
ties into civil society um and being
civic minded which is inclined to
concern oneself with affairs or public
spirited which is different from private
or household-based activities which i
term in my thesis personal or other
content
so this all comes together to
to make up the criteria that i'm using
to separate civic videos from personal
or other videos and i have further
categories which i'll get into also on
every slide you'll see little
images in the phones those are actually
still frames from videos live streamed
by some of the producers the civic
producers whom i interviewed so um and i
won't explain what they all are even
though i really want to but i can do
that later if you're interested because
they're fascinating um
so
just to quote henry since he's here and
he wrote extensively on sort of
trying to
trying to figure out what civic media is
um
so on his blog he had he'd used a quote
referencing or he he talked about lisa
gilman's idea of um lisa get him
suggested that medium should be
understood both as a technological
platform which is channel communication
and the social and cultural protocols
which grow up around it as we think
about future civic media we are not
simply designing tools or devices that
might be deployed to support and sustain
citizenship we're also talking about the
practices that grow up around those
devices practices that shape how they
get used and how they're understood by
the people who use them so that's
that's i'm using as a kind of framework
for my analysis here
i'll get more
more to that approach just brief context
why is this important it's a pretty new
medium
even from the time i started studying
this a lot more services have propped up
to support live streaming mobile video
a lot of money and industry being poured
into this it's an accessible technology
in the sense that it's affordable
marginally in terms of you just need a
phone that has camera
it's becoming increasingly more
affordable as data plans are more
affordable it's an understudied area a
lot of the existing research really
focuses on
the use of
still photos and sharing
there's been some good research on
the potential for
mobile technology to promote democracy
and organize grassroots movement
um or to improve local economies and
social services in developing countries
especially through sms
but not as much about
mobile video because it really is pretty
new so i'm really um
i'm analyzing mobile video as a specific
medium through which producers can
become specifically engaged and i'm
offering a technical analysis of content
to add interviews with people to explore
how much does have some big value and
what does that mean um and just to lean
on a quote from ill folk skinning who's
one of the few scholars who's really
been focusing on mobile video
he was talking about flickr
supporting mobile video and he was
saying as far as i can say no studies of
the content that pages like this have
been conducted obviously a good deal of
material is just entertainment
consisting of funny or non-ordinary
occasions in ordinary life however more
serious content is also delivered
through these services and that
serious content is really what i'm
interested in and what i'm calling civic
content
and my backgrounds in video production
and activism so that all
blends nicely i've been using the site
as well for a few years just to test it
out so i really wanted to write about it
um key
questions a few basic ones
what type of content is actually being
produced is actually being broadcast
online through mobile videos very
general um not just civic but in general
what are people filming how can we
identify demographic transaction i'm
talking about
age location
or that type of thing um how much of
content in this new medium actually has
a big value and what
factors encourage producers to capture
and stream the type of footage and also
is there can we come up with a profile
of the type of general civic producer is
that even possible and what are the
context in which that these people are
producing media um so my interviews were
really focused on assessing the
motivations behind production
um
and then
research methods i
knew there was a few ways i could go at
this
every approach was a little bit limiting
so i wanted to merge both quantitative
and
qualitative so i did a quantitative
survey
um
with a thousand videos of a period of
five months i
measured a lot of general stats for the
videos whether they were shot in public
private and um
came up with what of the civic value
tags ways to categorize whether
something had civic value of course this
is very subjective i'm
doing this myself if someone else were
to approach the study they might choose
different categories they might choose a
different way of categorizing this but i
felt that this was appropriate i chose
journalistic political activistic
educational and religious for my value
tag specific videos and then also
some additional tags for videos that
were not necessarily civic i mean
personal videos entertainment
professional touristic and promotional
just to get a larger sense of what was
being produced i also did qualitative
interviews um
with
i contacted a lot of people ended up
speaking with seven people to borrow the
ghost of lana schwartz's
thesis presentation from last year using
an ethnographic stand more particularly
as ito and acaba called a technosocial
approach
which is really uses anthropological
analysis to interpret the technologies
that underlie
social activity
and grounded theory methods to interpret
to deconstruct and analyze my my
qualitative data my interview
content and as i mentioned i was really
talking to people to assess
what motivated them to use this what
were the
what characterized their practice of
production
and their adoption level or their issues
and challenges and if there are other
trends that i can identify that are
useful
so there's a number of things that i did
not study
i did not look at video reception it's a
big area i really wanted to concentrate
on production as a practice
i did not unfortunately i had no way to
systematically measure age race
ethnicity or my economic status of
producers i would have loved to do that
i think it would be really a ripe area
for further research
i made some generalizations based on
just physically what i saw when i was
watching these it seemed like a pretty
diverse range of
people producing this where they were
from what their backgrounds were like in
terms of the context in which they're
filming their homes um
i didn't look at interaction the site
supports if someone posts a comment in
real time while someone is live
streaming it'll show up on the person's
phone we'll be able to see oh i have two
viewers and one of them just wrote a
little comment i can react while i'm
filming to that
really interesting features are emerging
in this space with interaction
i didn't look at that because it's also
its own thesis
and distribution of content in the sense
of
um every all the people i spoke with
cross distributed their content quick
has really good social integration a
social media integration of just with
one click you can spread it to all your
your networks
but um i didn't focus too much on what
happened to that content once it's
spread out into space or if news
agencies pick it up or anything and i
really limited this to just people
within the us and the eu who are english
speakers for practical reasons and also
because that's the cultural context that
i can best understand
so hopefully
well okay um
just to give you an over i want to get
into the interesting stuff which is the
results so that's why i'm speaking
really fast um these are basically my
chapters structure of inquiry
introduction with key terms and overview
of my argument
i talked a little bit about the
historical parallels between
civic production and different forms of
media across time and issues then and
now especially in
public production
then i look at my survey results and
sort of break down those numbers try to
identify friends in production um the
fourth chapter motivating factors is
really um
based on my interview data with
producers and what they were
conceptualizing as
you know things that really
made them want to continue doing this
type of production um and i boiled that
down to liveness immediacy mobility real
imagined audience and
self-identification and then in my
conclusion i really i would like to be
able to offer some suggestions for
um
the design of future applications to
support not just live streaming mobile
video but this particular type of
producer specific producer
um so research findings
this is a provocative statement almost
exclusively men
it was um
there are nine percent identifiable
women in my general survey of all videos
um and the numbers are the percentages
are pretty much the same for just civic
videos of seven percent women
um so this is a pretty male
thing right now um there was a
a good range of older people i was
surprised i expected a lot more younger
people and that's really not what i
found
between you know 25 and over and a lot
of people in the 40 and over range and
the 15 over range again i don't have
real stats for this because i did not
measure up for age but
i would say definitely more than half
were over 40.
um
and also a lot of this is just
experimentation people were it's a new
medium people are experimenting with it
they're showing their friends they're
making little test videos and they're
really excited about it this is the
general thing i found also an important
insight from my interviews with people
um you know you hear a lot on the news
about these random people who
some accident or newsworthy event
happens and they happen to pull out
their phone and film it and that's great
but that's really not the
the profile of the typical civic
producer that i found i found these are
people who are already engaged in some
activities those are the ones who are
appropriating this um they're seeing
this as yet another tool um
for
um doing what they're already doing and
as uh scholar gergen calls nomadic
clusters of interest so these are videos
that are going to have value within
people's
uh circles if they're an educator if
they're a journalist they're an activist
that's the people that are gonna value
the content that they're producing
and then um one guy i talked to who made
this this is still from his video the
christian rocker
he's in a christian rock band and he
also films all of his church services so
this is what that is um
he's originally from sri lanka but he
lives in texas now and he was he and i
were talking about
why um my data pointed to more civic
videos coming out of places like brazil
and mexico and maybe less developed
countries and he was saying well in sri
lanka my family knows about this they
like it but they can't really pay for it
because we don't have they don't have
the data packages they do in the us it's
really expensive and he said well maybe
you know you're seeing more serious
footage in
developing countries because people are
paying for it and they don't want to
just stream their cute dog or their baby
as you see a lot of them in the states
they want to film a politician or
something that they consider really
important
and then i would talk to them about
desirable features that they would want
to see in future applications
so quantitative data i only picked two
charts to show you which just overview
my the categories that i gave to these
civic videos and there were overlaps in
there um and then as you can see on the
right the most of the civic footage is
being produced in public spaces versus
the personal or other footage is kind of
an even split between
public and private the main thing to to
look at here is i found that 11 based on
my category is 11 of the footage that i
watched was had specific value um and
that was largely journalistic and
educational
um i already talked about the gender
discrepancy um
the average length was also interesting
there was about two a little over two
minutes for personal videos um or
nonstick videos and almost seven and a
half minutes for civic which
you know points to some interesting
trends and
people taking it more seriously they're
really editorializing they're filming
the whole you know whether it's a speech
or a meeting or a protest or something
they're really putting more time into it
um
this site that i looked at quick is
based in the u.s there are other sites
that are more popular in asia which is
why maybe i saw more of a trend of us
brazil uk mexico and
europe as sort of the main countries out
of the 80 that i found
in my study and then i investigated
hosting style which i won't go into but
was which was interesting because um
it's a style which people acknowledge or
don't acknowledge the camera and how
they sort of take the viewer through um
through the video
um so qualitative insights this is a
chart i know it's a lot of text it's the
chart of the people i talk to and where
they're from
they all self-identify
as
activists or educators journalists they
all cross-post their content in other
places um and half of them make personal
footage as well as just civic footage um
and then i just a few quotes from people
that that was interesting
the real imagine audience
is a big motivating factor for
production a lot of people have an idea
who their audience is or real stats onto
their audiences or they know that
they're going to share it within their
network other people
are really motivated most of the people
i spoke to are really motivated by the
potential for anyone to just stumble
upon their videos and become what i'm
calling accidentally educated
so one man alden
had explained to me i don't have a
specific audience in mind i try to reach
out to broaden audiences possible
i write about anything i can think of
partly to bridge different communities
to get people who think about one thing
to try and think about something else so
this afternoon i did a little bit of
live streaming of the snowstorm so
people will come in and look at my
videos because they're interested in
looking at the snowstorm and hopefully
then they'll look over at the board of
education meeting or look at the speech
that a candidate
gave
um and he wasn't the only one almost
everyone i talked to was really even if
only two viewers from
the random internet
stumbled upon his video
that was enough for him to say okay cool
maybe two people learned something and
that was enough for him to want to
produce more
um
so finally just
areas of future research i really
already went over this
but the the things that i didn't really
look at the viewer reception i'm
interested in also the actual impact of
videos um in terms of what happens once
they're out there
being using as legal evidence one of my
producers had their footage used in a
legal case in thailand um
you know whether major media picked it
up
again demographics where are the women
what about this trend of older users
using this this is something that should
be more studied and then the nightmare
of archiving once if a thousand videos
of stream per day to just this one site
and there's a lot more sites and it's
growing every day what does this mean
not just
you know youtube's problem of archiving
everything but also for civic content
what happens when this valuable footage
goes unorganized
so those are all my issues and that's my
presentation
um i have a question about the word
civic um
you can't ask that i know you were i
know you were talking about uh you were
dealing with this earlier in the early
years i was curious about whether you
would come to any sort of conclusions
but i know you talked a little bit but
it seems like there might be the
possibility for the idea of what counts
as civic production um to be shaped by
the kinds of products the kinds of
things that you're looking at right like
so when you go in and you want to
categorize things as civic in various
ways do you think that uh it's possible
that say these people who are doing
putting up videos for various reasons
are
while doing that redefining what counts
as civic which might make a problem for
your category it's interesting you bring
that up because i think i missed a very
important point
um when i was rushing through my
presentation which is that the way that
i
ascribe value to these thinkers analyze
this is you know interpretive textual
analysis so like i i evaluated each
video based on my reading of the
inherent worth of the text itself
obviously someone else might read it
differently but that's how i placed it
within these categories
and because that i couldn't really know
what the producer's intent was or what
you know something that i thought was
just a stupid silly video maybe they
really thought
oh no i'm doing this educate people or
i'm you know it has different value and
that's another reason why i wanted to
couple this with interviews with people
because i really wanted to have
conversations with people because maybe
there's things that i miss um so it's
problematic because i couldn't i mean
there's no way i could not be so that i
could be objective unless i had a team
of people that would
help with reliability but
um
no it's a good time
well building off that it sounds like
you interviewed producers who you
thought were doing civic stuff
rather than interviewing a mix of people
someone who were doing civic stuff some
of them weren't
right would you would have found
something different if you talk to
people it's interesting because right
right when i first started this i had
kind of
gone into it thinking that i would do
what you just got is interviewing both
your average viewer who just films their
dog or whatever and i found let me tell
you really wonderful
interesting videos that i was dying to
talk to producers about it really came
down to feasibility and time
the interviews that i did do even though
not you know only seven but it took a
lot of time and i wasn't i realized i
wasn't going to be able to
invest that level of and i really
because i wanted to focus on the ones
that were obviously civic and that they
would describe this the same way
i had to make that call if i had more
time this was a phd dissertation poorly
i i think that is
that would be really interesting
do you have any thoughts on where this
whole medium is moving and funny you
should ask because
i do i think it's very timely um i think
it's sort of heartening and
interesting that in the six seven months
i've been looking at this issue all
these other sites have propped up um
just this week bamboozler which is like
the quick of sweden um
launched has launched a partnership with
emergency services
company like emts
and and they're allowing the emergency
workers and journalists to use this um
on the scene as a way to get there first
and say here's the conditions and then
emergency personnel will come and it's
their private videos um
but
that's one of the first things i've seen
recently that really speaks to
commercial partnerships or public
private partnerships in this realm and i
think that could have really great
potential and of course cnn reports
things where you know national
out news outlets are soliciting content
from producers that's through the
existing model but i think
maybe we're beginning to see a lot more
a bigger shift is there any evidence of
collaborative networks of people
no but my producers that i spoke with
one in particular we talked about the
snowstorm thing in the board of
education meetings um
who ironically was on a panel with henry
like in the dean campaign in 2004 just
randomly i found on the internet he's
like oh compared to me these studies um
he was saying that that's that's i told
people about what they want the future
what teachers they want and he was
saying something that could support that
that could be a way for people maybe
people who cover the same event that
don't know each other but then are live
streaming it to be able to find that
content online and maybe pull it down
edit it into a larger thing um
so that is a feature that people want
they want push production a little bit
of editing features after it's streamed
once it's archived and that doesn't
exist right now
and it should
yeah i mean the the question of what
civic i think is is interesting and i
think it's fine to use the term
but it is one of those
terms that has the danger i guess of of
civic being the politics that i like uh
you know and this has been a complaint a
lot of civil society researchers saw
power is another one of these that
i think that's the same kind of problem
i don't think you should throw it out
because of that but but it raised the
question how to contextualize it because
you know and that's sort of i guess back
to henry and some of the other questions
as well but so what's the relationship
between the entertainment and the civic
and i think you're right that it has
something to do with a
self-identification it's
politics outside the political system i
think that's what makes it civic i i
think of that as sort of civil society
versus government
but then there are ways in which
entertainment's very much a part of this
world too uh you know it's like i always
wonder why
parents are so terrified of having their
children walk around outside it was a
big thing 20 years ago i'm not sure it's
that much
more dangerous now but i know we have a
lot more entertainment now that has
children being used
by random people out there and i always
feel like all this nci csi
sort of uh
public sphere
then creates it's entertainment but it
has this political this this sort of
sense of danger the need for police the
role of police why forensics is is the
be all end all and so you know it would
be interesting then to think about that
relationship you know because i also
imagine that the people filming their
cat or their dog
if you said you know do you think this
has some civic meaning they would say
yes
you know i think people don't recognize
the importance of cats and dogs uh
and and i think this will help humans be
better people uh and solve problems in
the world and so i think so it would
just be interesting you know
something related to that one of the
people um
um he runs a website promoting sikh
um religion and culture
he's the guy and
he filmed this which is an intricate
chanting session
um
and he just got here um but he had a
different perspective similar to what
you're talking about or he had said uh
he's using my own life and community as
a way of being very real when you have
very formal journalistic type content
it's very different it's a very
different field than when you see real
people
um and informal type settings part of
having things this way for me is so that
people can see we're all on the same
level and not better or different
whatever i do i try to break down the
virus misunderstanding prejudice
judgment hate and the hope that people
will see each other's part the same so
his whole thing was
what he considered his typical content
wasn't just the religious ceremonies he
was filming but like the everyday here's
my son
in his traditional way of dressing and
here's our daily life because he wanted
it to be huma you know humanized
um he wanted people to see
to break down misunderstandings and i i
think that was a really interesting
example and
i'm sure that a lot of other people
would say that too and participant
observation is a nice term too i mean
anthropologists use that term but but
often it's in the service of a
relativistic view of culture whereas the
activist says is participant observation
where emphasis on participate and do
something uh and i think you know that i
think that's also part of the civic
world that's very powerful it's it's
journalists too step back i think
usually from saying i'm trying to change
i'm saying i'm reporting on the world
and so that's where this is this
interesting space that uh you know by
drawing out some of the nuances of it to
really help us see the limitations of
what is what else is out there and also
like what's the difference between how
they're conceptualizing who's watching
this and who's actually watching it
which right now on this site this is
really a community of people producing
not people sitting there watching you
stream which is a similar service has a
lot of people ready to watch content
whereas quick does not and
so that
there's a disconnect there
in terms of impact
um fully floor made forum question in my
head but i'm interested in um thinking
about the civic of like you know forums
for debate and discussion which sounds
like we're doing an interesting job of
like
presenting more platforms for people and
more voices
which is great we're hearing from people
you never would have heard of before but
do you see any back and forth between
videos with like people
i mean you can't do it simultaneously
but people addressing each other or
right now not in not
the platform doesn't support that in the
way that youtube will say responses to
this and people can do video responses
but
i did ask everyone about what have you
got in terms of feedback and how has
that been important to you and every
single person
and i don't even know if this is true i
kind of don't think that it's i don't
know if it's completely true but like
everyone said yeah i get feedback
whether it's an email or a comment
whether it's just from one random person
or someone who saw it on my facebook
page she's not even part of my network
and that really meant a lot to me and
that keeps me doing this
um
you're related
oh
this off yeah no i just had a question
that sort of i think does
a little bit um i saw one of your uh
charts he said
and i was wondering how
how the whole ecosystem works and like
how
you know like do they put where do you
put the stuff how does it work in other
spaces and how does it all work together
yeah the integration that's built into
quick is you know the typical
stuff stuff so twitter facebook um
it actually integrates with other sites
too like justin tv other video sharing
sites so
you know you can sort of with one click
spread it but then now so you can
anyone can go and um
share it to blogs or with embedding
within their own site and everyone that
i talked to seemed to do that um
actively because they knew that that's
really the only way to expand their
viewership there wasn't a lot of people
just randomly watching this um
so
i think they all know that's important i
just think that the platforms could
could build up
more of that integration whether that's
through commercial partnerships with
other sites or
thank you